we're going to begin this morning with
an extraordinary development in the
january 6 investigation former president
trump's chief of staff mark meadows is
being held in contempt of congress for
refusing to cooperate this comes as
witnesses are now saying that people in
the trump white house were aware in
advance that the day's events could turn
violent nicole killian is following all
of this on capitol hill nicole good
morning this is a stunning turn
yeah absolutely gail and this contempt
referral will now be in the hands of the
justice department making mark meadows
the first former white house chief of
staff to face potential criminal charges
since the watergate era
the resolution is adopted in a chamber
where mark meadows once served we need
to send a clear message
that this sort of defiance of the rule
of law cannot stand the house sought
criminal contempt charges against former
president trump's white house chief of
staff mark meadows is our former
colleague this is as wrong as it gets
the nearly party line vote came as the
january 6 select committee revealed new
text messages to meadows from unnamed
republican lawmakers where they discuss
potential ways to overturn the results
of the election here's an aggressive
strategy why can't the states of georgia
north carolina pennsylvania and other
r-controlled state houses declare this
is bs or conflicts in election not cold
that night and just send their own
electors to vote and have it go to the
scotus committee vice chair liz janey
took it a step further suggesting the
former president may have illegally
obstructed an official proceeding of
congress which is a felony did donald
trump
through action or inaction corruptly
seek to obstruct or impede congress's
official proceeding to count electoral
votes meadows claims he offered the text
messages and thousands of documents in
good faith but couldn't testify about
them because of executive privilege this
is not about a real investigation this
is about a real political
narrative the former white house chief
of staff is the third trump associate
facing a contempt citation by the select
committee although about 300 other
witnesses have cooperated that includes
dustin stockton who organized a series
of events leading up to january 6.
i do have some regret over how things
turned out while stockton and his
attorney say he didn't take part in the
violence at the capitol he and lead
rally organizer amy kramer did raise red
flags about the possibility do you know
if those concerns were elevated to mark
meadows my text messages make it clear
that they were elevated to the campaign
and the white house so you think meadows
knew i took that i said
meadows absolutely new
stockton has turned over communications
to the panel and his fiancee is set to
be deposed today meantime john eastman
an attorney who advised the former
president on ways to overturn the
election is suing the select committee
and verizon to block the release of his
cell phone records tony
meanwhile you've got republican liz
cheney in a prominent role there in the
investigation nicole thank you very much